oh I just love the smell of a good
royalty deal in the morning ken this is
it the shark takes them right here these
tables these chairs right here baby
this is where it happens come down that
corridor
it's got to take a lot of guts to walk
through that thing when the doors are
closed knowing what's on the other side
west side the doors are closed they're
freaking out for sure they don't know
what's on the other side because they've
always been practicing with other sharks
there then they make the walk then think
that that that that that the door is
open up then it gets really tough I mean
haven't watched me for ten years but I
know it sorry
you know what's gonna happen in about 20
minutes and start all over again I love
this show it's so much fun to make
because every deal is different and
after all you only need one good idea it
changes your life forever
[Music]
what is this so where's the white space
in your portfolio right now what kind of
deal haven't you done that you kind of
want to do like you've got a sec I want
to do music it's all the producers we
don't do enough music stuff you do
everything else it's hard to find a deal
in music that you know is an re owned by
the behemoth
you know we've had bands and stuff like
that but we don't finding them a music
deal would be very cool that would
definitely be an interesting
[Music]
I'm also interested in doing more with
gourmet foods because I've got chef
wonderful that was pretty big franchise
on QVC selling out everything to bring
their iPod cakes who may be doing
chocolates and so if I see more gourmet
items that would fit in my chef
wonderful portfolio I'm gonna go for
that stuff seems like Daymond and
Barbara that's all that's all about to
change now is chef wonderful full steam
ahead I'm gonna crush them with the
cockroaches they are where we've
realized we don't have the same amount
of value it's on business-to-business
stuff because why would you give up you
think of a syndication you're getting 10
million eyeballs a week you want a
product that everybody wants to buy
that's what works when you get
sophisticated technology that only a
business buys it's a limited opportunity
and over time see mostly investors don't
do those deals because they don't add a
lot of value where I add value is
product needs to get out to the open
market
[Music]
see I'm going with all the healthy
options Sal asparagus and tomato
mozzarella very clean living here who
gives a flying
where is it like to be in the tank with
Kevin in the tank would you be mr.
wonderful mr. wonderful he doesn't like
dog like Kevin you've got to address him
but it's virtually impossible to be in
the tank without wine
Chateaubriand and death coming up with
gathers houses French sprays terrible
you just said he takes the word
Chateaubriand oh shut up Liam and that's
his French pretending to be a Quebec
walk if you would like those votes but
let's be honest all together they're
caramelizing with it but flambe at the
end for each this masterpiece any
where's the advice for fellow
entrepreneurs I think if you're coming
to the tank be confident be passionate
and please please please have a real
plan
[Music]
[Music]